- [Mark] I know you don't
care what other people think.
You do things your own
way, which is beautiful.
All right, Lin.
Lin, what's new?
How've you been?
- I've been all right.
Been through a lot.
I still don't have a job.
But tomorrow I'm gonna start looking.
- [Mark] You start working tomorrow?
- No, I'm gonna start looking.
- You start looking.
It's hard right now, 'cause of the,
everything that's going on.
What's going on, where are you living now?
- I'm back on the streets.
- [Mark] You were staying
with a friend for a while?
- Yeah.
- But now you're back
on the streets of Hollywood?
- Yeah.
I don't just stay in
Hollywood now, though.
I just, like, go wherever I want.
- So you roam around?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Just stay away
from Skid Row (chuckling)?
- Yeah, I don't come down here.
- Good.
- Except for this.
- Except for me.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Cool.
What's going on with the two court cases?
- I got court in June, early June.
I'm gonna go to, it's just for
a plead of guilty or innocent.
So, a plea, I guess.
I'm gonna plead innocent.
- [Mark] And you have
a lawyer and all that?
- A public defender.
- Public defender, okay.
And there's two cases or one?
- I think this is just for the one.
'Cause the one with the--
- [Mark] The second one,
the guy's backed off, right?
- The second one, with the guy,
the one that I actually, you know.
I think that's the one
that I'm gonna be pleading innocent to.
I'm not sure which one it is.
I think that's the one, though.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And then what's going on with the
crystal meth and alcohol
and stuff like that?
- I'm gonna be honest,
I'm super thin right now because of it.
But I kicked it about a week ago.
- The crystal meth?
- Yes.
Not a week ago, maybe like
between four to seven days ago.
- [Mark] Okay. And how's
that going for you?
- It's going pretty good.
I mean, I know I say I kick it a lot,
but there are actually
reasons as to why I do it.
- [Mark] And alcohol?
Is that--
- I drink every now and then.
Whenever it's around or whatever.
- [Mark] Do you not hit
the bottle every day?
- No, no.
No, I'm not really into drinking profusely
on the streets 'cause you never know
what could happen to
yourself or your things.
- [Mark] Yeah, absolutely.
What's going on with your mom?
Have you talked to her?
- Nope.
- [Mark] Do you have
friends on the street?
- Yeah, yeah, I know a lot of people.
- [Mark] People you trust?
- And a lot of people like me, yeah.
- (chuckling) A lot of people out there.
- Yeah.
A lot of people like me.
- [Mark] And your video
got a lot of views.
Do people recognize you from the videos?
- No, like, on the streets?
- Yeah.
- No, no.
- No?
People on the street probably
don't watch the show.
- No, they don't (chuckling).
They're cool with me because I
got their back in a safe way.
- [Mark] You help out some
of the people on the street?
- Yeah, actually, I've been
buying for the homeless.
Been buying for the homeless.
If somebody asks for a
cigarette, if I have it,
I give it to 'em, no questions asked.
If they ask for a dollar or two,
I give it to 'em if I have it.
Being super generous and
it's working out for me.
- [Mark] That's nice, that's nice to hear.
Anything bad happen to you
when you're on the street?
- Recently?
- Yeah.
- On the streets, no.
- No?
- No.
- [Mark] It just seems like
there's always drama out there.
- Yeah, yeah, but it's harmless drama.
Actually, just the other
night, no, the other day,
I think it was yesterday,
actually, I heard this guy
was beating on this chick
that I've never talked to
but I've seen her around
and I went up to him.
And I had a metal pole and I
sat down and I talked to him
and I said, hey, did you hit her?
And he's like, only like this.
And I'm like, I got really
angry and I yelled at him
and threatened him and I told
him, if you ever do that.
And I hit his tent with the pole
and almost broke the tent pole.
I think I might have.
I don't know.
It's probably just bent
a little or something.
I don't know.
But I told him if he ever does that again,
then he's gonna get fucked up.
- [Mark] Quitting crystal
meth, is that something you,
I mean, how has that gone?
How difficult is that?
- Me, personally, it's not that difficult
because it's not really a need to me.
- You're not really addicted?
- It's all in the mind.
If you think you need
it, then you need it.
- [Mark] Would you consider
yourself an addict?
- No, no.
- No.
- 'Cause a lot of people
smoke because they like
the feeling of smoke
going into their lungs,
not because of what they're smoking.
It's not self-sabotage.
It's considered calming.
Smoke can help some people.
- [Mark] Absolutely.
People love to bash on cigarette smoke
but there's actually benefits to it.
Where do you see your
life going from here?
- [Lin] Nowhere but up.
- [Mark] It's nice that
you're gonna look for work.
That's great.
Are you liking California?
- Yeah.
No matter how bad it gets, no matter
how good it gets, I ain't leavin'.
Unless it's to go to another state
for something I need or something
that I feel I need to be
there for, then I ain't goin'.
- [Mark] Is rehab something
you think you need, now?
Or not so much?
You were talking about that at one point.
- [Lin] I mean, I'm gonna be honest.
If I ever feel like I need
meth because of my weight,
then I'm probably just gonna snort some.
Because it has different
effect than smoking.
- [Mark] Or just call me
and I'll buy you a pizza.
- [Lin] Pizza won't.
- [Mark] It won't do the trick for ya?
- No.
- Works for me.
- [Lin] I'm just being honest.
That's just me personally.
If I feel I need it,
then I'm gonna get some.
I'm gonna strengthen up.
It's gonna make me smarter for the moment.
- [Mark] What does
crystal meth do for you?
It kinda wakes you up?
- [Lin] It makes me smarter.
It makes me really flirty.
But I know my limits and I
know how to control myself.
- [Mark] So your goal is to
get a job, get off the street?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Hopefully get
past the court cases.
- Well, maybe not get off the street.
But get a job, definitely.
Because I'm not even comfortable
sleeping in an apartment.
I sleep on the floor whenever
I'm in somebody's apartment.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What do you
think that's all about?
That you're more comfortable on the street
or on the floor of an
apartment than a bed?
- Because I don't see why
people waste their time
and their money trying
to keep a house clean
and being comfortable
whenever animals don't do that
and they're perfectly fine.
They're natural, they're healthy,
they're living off the Earth.
You know?
Yeah.
- [Mark] And you have
a brother, too, right?
- I have a stepbrother, yeah.
- [Mark] A stepbrother?
- A few.
- Do you ever talk to him?
- No.
What would you say to all of the viewers
that love you and relate
to you and care about you?
- I would tell them all just to be happy
with their lives and do
what makes them happy.
And that I appreciate their
support and everything.
Yeah.
- [Mark] Cool.
All right, Lin.
Great seeing you again.
- All right, you, too.
- [Mark] Good luck with finding
work and everything else.
- All right.
- Great, thanks.
- No problem.